quit pause thank you so much Squarespace
for sponsoring this video enjoy the
video
cool alright so welcome to my channel so
can you tell me a little bit about
yourself we know that you're a compelled
programmer but just a little bit about
your life I am coming or erecta and I
like competitive programming to the
degree that I decided to work in
competitive programming not only I
participate in those contests I also
organize the contests programming comes
preparing for a wife for Olympiad for
high schoolers right now I'm in USA for
Google Code Jam because I advance to the
finals and this is some part of my life
that a few times a year I go to some
international competition plus I have a
YouTube channel where I teach
algorithms nice so Google Code Jam what
does it take to get to the final because
I never even got past the preliminary
basically it's not about maybe preparing
something for the few days before the
contest it's about being very good in
other games
and obviously for that you need years to
practice maybe months if you are very
very good and then there are several
qualification rounds I think three plus
one extra preliminary qualification
round and then 225 people I think
advance to the finals that's it just 25
I think 25 plus the champion from the
previous year so 26 who was the champion
from the previous year and Gennady
courage courage actually he was taken
for the last five years holy oh my god
so he doesn't need to take the
preliminary rounds he just goes straight
to the final Coco so can you talk to me
more about what is competitive
programming exactly yeah I think in
short it's a mind sport where instead of
like interests or poker you think about
cards on your next moves here you think
about programming how to program
something you were given a few problems
to solve with some time limit
constraints for data how big it can be
to invent quick enough a Gert a fish
until of and implemented in time and who
is fastest themselves the most problems
with do they usually care about the time
it takes to execute or just the
complexity that's a good question and
complexity is very important because
it's a difference of ranking one second
or one hour or day and there is usually
a time limit like two seconds as long as
you are within the time limit you're
okay
there are some competitions where it
might matter or so maybe a length of
count how good score your program
produces because this is some np-hard
problem that doesn't have an exact
solution it's just how good solution you
will find but most of the time is just
you need to pass it then you get the
number of points that is assigned to
this problem so for example Google Code
Jam at the end in the final how did you
guys compare programs is it mostly on
the time or at the corrections this is
one of those where it's only the
correctness and running within time and
then every problem has some score
assigned like this one is 15 points this
one is 20 because it's harder and the
hardest is say 40 and the sum of points
matters if there is a tie what happens
of course then when you submitted like
your last solution if somebody finished
in two and half hours then he's better
than somebody who got the same score if
ours also okay so how fast you do it
matters
yeah yeah what do you think you're gonna
place I think around top time should be
my expected last year I was second just
after cannibals that is crazy
yeah but this was my one of highest
performance in my life not that I expect
to repeat that I hope of course
mmm-hmm so can you give me an example of
what a competitive programming problem
is okay I will give you I think a cool
example I probably can't solve it but
mister I think you can okay you
overestimate it it will show some point
of mine okay that side there is there
was a tennis match or it can be valuable
it's Marisol if I hold that and you're
given a sequence of letters I and we
whoever player a or b scored the point
and there are some rules in tennis you
need some some number of points to win a
set then game which I don't know I don't
know very much myself yeah you're given
a sequence for the whole match and you
need to tell which player one like won
the whole game exactly
hunt of course you can implement all of
that yeah to say now of course if there
is a tie at the end of Saturday they
still need to play maybe for a long time
it's not like whoever gets four points
or whatever that means immediately yeah
and you can implement that in say 10
minutes I don't know I mean yeah what
I'm gonna do it's very very simple right
we have a string of like a ba ba ba B
and then because I know the rules of
tennis
imagine if I do it know the rules of
tennis I'm just gonna increment the
points and then if it's a set they
already want to set it's just okay he
want to set so I just listen all right
exactly so you would do that and usually
what happens during contest is that you
see a problem you think for a moment
about how to implement it implement
maybe the back for a little bit you
spend say 10 minutes you look at the
leaderboard and you solved you see that
somebody solve it in 30 seconds how is
it possible you might ask oh do they
have like preset code that they already
wrote not necessary maybe it's about
like pasting in C++ include something
into nine ways so when you mean
30-second do you mean the runtime was
thirty second or do they submit it
you've read that problem and implement
it and submit in France if I guess they
already heard the question no it's about
quickly coming up with a simple idea
idea and here the idea is that you print
the last letter Oh Casey oh yeah because
if you already want you're the one that
and you know this drink is ID whatever
happens under the inversion well that
says let's assume me
that's assuming the string is correct
and that's a good point there is some
say disadvantage of people used to
competitive programming is that they
always assume that data is correct some
the statement said something that there
is that sequence describing the match or
if the see if the statement said that
you're given a sequence of numbers that
are in this interval they will be in
this interval they don't care about
incorrect characters maybe some number
being non integer they just do what they
are told so they might miss something in
real job when they should ask what if my
what if user will give me incorrect date
oh yeah that's super smart yeah just
look at the last letter of the string he
won yeah there isn't one
cool I like that this is fun okay and
and then would you say would you say
competitive programmers make good
software engineers or if there's no
relation it's very hard and I I've seen
an article that size there is a negative
correlation for sure they are smart like
people in the top of competitive
programming are very smart but on the
other hand they are maybe over skilled
in algorithms that isn't that important
in a job what is important that you
implement carefully that you are able to
debug stuff this I think this is easy
for competitive programmers they make a
lot of mistakes so they need to collect
correctly all the time but there are
some skills that they don't have they
are good candidates and some of them
will be awesome workers
some of them will not that make sense
that make sense so what are like the
biggest contests and platforms for
competitive programming I already
mentioned code versus this is Russian
platform there is also Japanese ad coder
American top coder which is a very old
platform like almost 20 years it was one
first while the other two are quite
young and they organize contests online
every week I think so if you combine all
those platforms plus several that I
didn't mention you will have contests
every second day or so
plus there are some big insights from
time to time like Google culture
TopCoder open facebook hacker cup some
of them are just organized by big
companies to attract skilled
participants and maybe hire them a
Google Code Jam actually is I think the
well-prepared
one also with a stream quite
professional stream that has a lot of
advertisement know that they will
advertise Google stadia this year during
the stream but it's also for programmers
so there's a lot of clips work with us
this is eco intern please tell us what
you do and why you like Google yeah it's
like one big advertisement of course
still I don't complain because I get to
compete with other strong competitors I
have a chance to win money and I have a
trip to USA oh yeah that's true oh did
he pay for your flight here yes leader
it's what about hotel they cover hotel
sometimes five-star one so I have been
to few 5-star hotels only because some
competitions made for that what's the
price for like first place second place
right now it's around 10,000 or 15,000
dollars which is fine especially fuel if
not in a rich country in Europe it's
more for example in Poland but it used
to be so much more really even one
hundred thousand dollars for doing why
is it so long right now I think that but
this is only my foot that maybe because
once it mean such money you don't have
an incentive to work in the company
because yeah yeah yeah Google wants to
get those best people so they shouldn't
give them money upfront okay maybe just
a side question do you used to do math
competitions I did not actually in high
school till maybe middle of high school
I did maps instead of informatics and I
even went to some international on sites
maybe not as big as Google Code Jam but
is I was I think one of the best in
Poland on my year
and a lot of people in competitive
programming are very good in maths yes
some of them didn't study computer
science
they studied maths or economics so is it
very similar solving for these math
questions and solving for coding
questions I think the skills required to
comprehend all of that to understand the
logic implications to prove that
something will work are similar I see
you need a lot of knowledge that is only
for algorithms but the same people are
good in both do people usually do
competitive programming join university
and then do they stop after because it
seems like everyone's so young yeah most
of people are young maybe also because
company's programming almost didn't
exist 20 years ago there are only a few
guys that are in the top and over 30
most of people study a lot in high
school maybe to prepare for Iowa if they
are very competitive and skillful in
university for ICPC competition or just
to get to some company because coding
interviews are also about algorithms so
competitive programming is maybe a place
to to try to learn a bit to compare
yourself with others plus there are
competitions like Google kickstart that
are more mainstream for programmers and
you have a chance to that if you are
good there Google might invite you to an
interview nice and after university once
you have a job already
maybe you start a family you don't have
time anymore to practice like several
hours a week then why would you continue
that that's sure some people still do
because they enjoy it but not a lot yeah
I personally think it's a lot easier to
just apply to these jobs normally than
winning a competition do you think the
coding questions for the interviews are
similar to the competitive programming
questions or is that way easier so
regarding the first question how easy it
is to get for competitions it's not that
you have to win like Google kickstart to
be invited
200 maybe even top 500 is enough that
you can say that while applying and
maybe they will give you the first
interview because of that ok still you
will quickly final if you aren't good
maybe in other areas but it's a chance
to be recognized compared to thousands
of people maybe tens of thousands and
problems are similar competitive
programming is harder because it's for
people that train
sometimes here's for that it needs to be
harder but there are just some
differences when competitive programming
requires some complicated algorithms
coding interviews sometimes can ask you
questions that aren't possible to be
tested with computer like maybe some
parallel computing with thousands of
machines you will not meet such a
problem in competitive programming
because organizers don't want to get
thousands of machines to test your
program Google organized such a
competition one with hundreds of
machines testing your program but it had
some limitation it was called
distributed culture call coding
interviews have also sometimes other
problems that cannot appear in
competitive programming like for example
inventing an algorithm that we work in
constant time for something like or in
logarithmic time given an array with
binary search some number because the
array is sorted it's very hard to test
with competitive programming because you
need to get that array anyway so the
time spent by computer tracker for that
needs to be at least linear complexity
anyway when you speak with somebody
during interview they can ask you what
about this can you achieve smaller
memory maybe try to get constant memory
well program that is automatically
judged sometimes has some limitations
like you cannot distinguish between two
complexities also then constant factor
matters so the fact that everything is
tested has the downside of not being
able to distinguish everything but also
has an advantage everything is fair and
objective it's not that interviewer
likes you
you better score yeah quick question so
in competitive programming does it ever
happen that the higher complexity is
actually better because the lower couple
sorry the higher complexity what if that
makes us like the higher complexity
might be faster and is a better because
like the constant is too high for like
the lower context it is that yes it
might happen right you need to
understand when you want to focus on
competitive programming you want you
need to understand for example that
hashlib hashmaps have quite high
constant factor if you can if values are
small anyway and they would fit in and
are I use an array instead everything
will be constant access anyway but it's
faster so this is one example and the
other is that maybe some complexities
theoretically worse but because of small
data actually like this even though it's
n square because n is small you don't
care about it you don't have to invent n
times logarithm somewhere so people
don't check your code during
competitions right they just run it even
it might happen that tests are very weak
they do not cover some case maybe edge
case or maybe your algorithm is
heuristic and it could be quadratic but
when data is random the summaries yeah
there are some algorithms like that and
organizers try to care about that that
pessimistic run time and they try to
create test cases
malicious test cases but they don't
always it's impossible to predict all
the interesting that's called they have
a card job so do people ever win because
they realize the tests aren't that good
so they can make their code like even
not cover all the edge cases but then
win because of that it might happen
especially during last minutes of a
competition now you know already that
you will you don't have time to come up
with so you just try whatever it might
be like in school writing some yes I
have been working here the
by random okay I CBI maybe it will pass
and just once every 10 or 100 items it
will that's funny
Coco Co so you have like you have
personally met again to the year is this
I have I have my team right can't get
him here I think you wouldn't need to
write to him like a few weeks ago
oh really uh okay well he is coming in
Google Code Jam right yes but you know
usually you plan those trips a few
months in advance and you already have
tickets
there's nothing now that you can do yes
sure well you know some people actually
will be here already in advance because
I asked several guys whoever they maybe
want to go to escape room together on
San Jose
that's fine intercourse really easy for
you guys yeah I think people in
companies programming are very good
inescapable and so I'm going to with
several strong guys and psycho says I
think that if there are some algorithmic
problems then process we will be very
good but he's not one of them sorry oh
yeah so what about any other competitors
like do they all are they all in school
what did he do for a living the the best
ones are does that still after
university they do something of course
they are some very skillful and talented
ones in high school or university but if
some other people have 10 years of
experience already they are better those
that enjoy the competitive programming
and they want to practice for the sake
of it because they like it and some of
them work in university like doing
research in algorithms sometimes in
machine learning I know a few guys that
started companies or startups on their
own or they do cool stuff like that they
don't compete anymore they do some of it
you know
they cannot spend 20 hours a week but if
they like something and their job is a
bit related to that it's good for them
to stay fresh with algorithms like new
algorithms in the world then they can
spend several hours a week and it's
still useful to some degree some people
work in university some in big companies
like Google there are also people like
me that just stay in competitive program
it's a bit like questioning skull why do
you need biology for and the question is
to teach yes sure of course there are
some uses and I also had internships
where I just strictly did a girl like
working on algorithm pannu selling
flight ticket working on algorithm to
combine single flights into something
with changes we don't do that with
machine learning because there is just
let's say thousands of possible sites
and you need to combine them in good
enough complexity this is exactly a
problem that could appear in the
programming contest interesting so do
you mind me asking like how old you are
and when you started compared for
whamming I am right now 24 and I started
I think when I was around 16 16 I knew
some of C++ maybe just a little bit of
Python 2 when I was 16 and when I was 17
or 18 I bought my first book I'm not
from a big city so and said that I had a
lot of friends to discuss with or to
learn from also not a lot of teachers
know programming algorithmic programming
the only in the university learned that
well I bought a book Carmen's
introduction to algorithms I've read
most of that and I could do it because I
was good in maths so then my my skills
my performance I think skyrocket
also the university meeting other
talented people competing with them in
team ICPC competition
and puree see that's pretty cool that's
pretty cool
what about AG Kennedy like when did he
start and like how old is he now
I think he started when he was like six
with coming and when he was 11 for the
first time he was in International
Olympiad for high school and I think for
the first time when he was there he
didn't win he won one here's 12 okay
yeah wait how old is he now my age or
maybe one year older I think he's 25
it's not even don't don't quote me on
that
okay okay that's cool so what do you
plan to do in the future like do you
think you just want to teach competitive
programming or do you want to do
something else you know what if
everything paid the same every job paid
the same what would you choose can they
just play games on ps4 you have to
extreme it okay awesome
so I guess you like playing games on ps4
yes but our girls are also cool if I
were to choose just till the end of my
life to do a groups or play games I
would choose algorithms because those
are more interesting to me cool cool
okay it's called the some of this and
some of that
yeah if everybody'd paid this you have
everything paid the same then I first
sure would continue with my youtube
channel
the driver for now I don't even have ads
so I earned zero for now for that and I
don't think it will change a lot in the
near future but I know that I help some
people
I receive messages that they like my
videos that they learned something
also sometimes I try coding interview
problems just to bring more people to
compare a programming this is something
that people search for and then maybe
some of them will just enjoy algorithms
and will stay there I also organize
camps teach in high school some system
yeah also from the organization's site
I'm not only teacher but also organizer
organizer of contests events
and I like that I will be doing that in
the future cool all right well thank you
so much for coming
do you want to talk about your channel a
little bit promote it or something so
basically if if you want to learn
algorithms then it's a good idea to
check my channel out but I guess that's
it the name of my channel is Arita we've
CH Harry CH how did you come up with
that username because that's the same as
their competitive programming yeah I use
director in the Internet and a lot of
people ask me about the meaning of that
and the answer is it's a bunch of random
letters there is huge advantage to that
it's never taken if you take something
from a book all right like your name
something like this it will be taken
yeah that's funny cool all right thank
you so much for the interview I really
appreciate it learned a lot thank you so
much see ya Squarespace gives people a
powerful and beautiful platform in which
you can create your website you can
create beautiful websites or an online
store using these award-winning
templates create beautiful websites with
Squarespace all in one platform so that
means you'll never have to install
things patch things or upgrade ever
Squarespace is used by a wide range of
creatives and people ranging from
musicians designers artists restaurants
youtubers and more if you're interested
go on squarespace.com slash Joma tech to
get your free trial and 10% off your
first purchase all right that's it